Morning is when the sun rises.
The sun rises early in the morning.
My day begins early in the morning when the sun rises.
I get up, wash my face, brush my hair, and get dressed.
I eat my breakfast and drink my juice.
Then I get ready for school.
Noon is when the sun is high in the sky.
It is lunchtime at school.
It is bright, and it is warm.
I eat lunch, and I play with my friends.
Afternoon is when the sun begins to go down.
I come home from school, and I eat a snack.
I play with my friends.
Evening is when the sun is lower in the sky.
It is getting darker.
I eat dinner with my family.
After dinner, I like to watch television.
I like to read my favorite books.
Then I get ready for bed.
Night comes after the sun has set.
The sky is dark.
The moon and stars are out.
I get into bed, and Dad reads me a story.
Then I go to sleep in my bed.
Teddy goes to sleep in my bed, too.